we went up to the Canadian Arctic and we  were not allowed to go off by ourselves  at all because of the polar bear threat  so we always had to have a guide with us  and the guide always put their dog when  we actually got to the field site we  would create a hole for the scuba diver  to get into the water because the  conditions are so extreme dives were  very short he could only be down for  about 20 minutes for a dive doing about  two dives a day  we can actually track by measuring  changes in the carbon chemistry of the  algae the changes in the atmospheric  that people are causing by burning  fossil fuels  we need to create records how the oceans  change because if we want to know how  people are changing it we have to know  how it changes by itself and the ocean  is absolutely an amazing massive dynamic  part of our world being a paleontologist  I realized that it's actually quite  back-breaking turning over a rock and  finding something underneath makes your  heart leap